[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast he works for cbs and
westwood one you can check out his ross
tucker football podcast how are you ross
dan awesome always i was just on chat
row with a bunch of your listeners love
chat row love being on your show let's
do it all right how was thanksgiving by
the way you are mr food
uh honestly well first of all you will
appreciate this
i was in dallas i did the raiders
cowboys for westwood one
they had a side carving station
of honey glazed ham
and smoked rib eye unbelievable but
here's what's funny about it
when i go up to get my ham and ribeye
the chef like the guy with the big hat
the irrationally big hat i don't know
why his hat needs to be so big but he
looked at me and said whoa
i said well he's like i thought you were
james van der beek for a second
and i said
no
i said no actually i am meathead james
van der beek according to the dan
patrick show that's that's one of the
only time that's ever happened i don't
look that much like the guy i mean i'm
way bigger and stronger i have a beard
but anyway he said that so the cowboys
probably had dan
the best press box food spread
i've ever been a part of i love my
mother-in-law she's a good cook
but the cowboys kind of kind of kind of
put her away all right that lost by the
cowboys like what has happened to the
cowboys recently that you can put your
finger on
well i think at a minimum
not having amari cooper and cd lamb
really really hurts them you know one of
the reasons why they were so dynamic and
dax an mvp candidate
is they've got an unbelievable receiving
trio you know gallup is a really good
number three
but he's not a great number one and i
think that was very limiting
for them offensively against the chiefs
when he got hurt and cooper didn't play
and against the raiders that's the big
reason why they didn't score enough
points in those games i think
defensively they were good against the
chiefs the problem defensively
against the raiders
nobody wants to throw the ball near
trayvon diggs for the interception
they attacked anthony brown he got four
pass interference penalties in one game
i have no idea dan why the nfl decided
it would be good idea to have 30
penalties on thanksgiving which is one
of like the three games a year some
people watch thanksgiving in the super
bowl they had a it was a four plus hour
game
but at any rate that's why the cowboys
lost
is all the past interference penalties
on anthony brown and they didn't score
enough because they didn't have cd lamb
or amari cooper
are they a contender for the super bowl
like a legitimate contender for the
super bowl
yeah i mean i still think it's going to
be the package of the bucks but yes i
think the cowboys will be in the mix i
think the arizona cardinals will be in
the mix i think when the cowboys have
all of their guys firing on all
cylinders both sides of the ball i still
think they are
as good as anyone i mean micah parsons
i can't remember the last time we saw a
rookie defensive player like this
i've had multiple people tell me they
think he's the best edge rusher in the
nfl already wow which is bananas he
didn't he opted out last year he played
linebacker the two years before that at
penn state he's a part-time edge rusher
this year and they think he's the best
in the whole league it's it's cr greg
cosell said that daniel jeremiah said
that it's really unbelievable
i was wondering about the mvp and and i
try not to go week to week and go hey
who's the mvp this week and i i'm really
kind of struggling to figure out who is
the most valuable player and i i kind of
fall back to
tom brady i don't know if aaron rodgers
it would be held against him that he
wasn't vaccinated and missed a really
important game against kansas city sort
of the way i looked at james harden when
people tried to make an mvp candidate
and he forced his way out of houston
came in out of shape i said he can't be
the most valuable player look at what he
did to his former team to get out of
there
do you think it would be held against
rogers that he missed a really important
game and lied about being vaccinated
yes honestly dan knowing the writers and
the people that vote for that award
even if he hadn't missed a game
the fact that he's not vaccinated some
of them will hold that against him and
the fact that he lied about it some of
them will hold it against him then you
add the fact that he missed a game and
they lost because of it i don't think
aaron rodgers has a prayer i think aaron
rodgers knows
he doesn't have a prayer i think brady
if you look at his numbers
i mean i haven't looked at it this week
but he was leading the nfl on touchdown
passes leading the nfl in passing yards
it's almost like we've gotten bored
of brady and we want to try to give the
award to somebody new like who's the
next big thing let's give it to dak
let's give it to kyler murray somebody
else please step up and take this it
feels like brady's the default option
and people are hoping anyone else steps
up it's like people don't want to see
alabama win the national championship
people don't want to see tom brady win
the mvp well it's also that they they
kind of anointed josh allen
and and it was going to be his year
almost like he's luca doncic like hey
you're special it's your year and i said
well dallas isn't going to be competing
for a title luke is not going to win the
mvp which of course he didn't josh allen
i thought there was way too much
pressure on him because i don't think
it's a great offense i think when he
does special things then it is a great
offense but i don't i'm like he's had
some bad runs here the last couple of
weeks with uh what's happened with
buffalo
you know what's weird dan i can't
remember a year
where there was sort of this much
uncertainty regarding the heisman trophy
and nobody really seemed to take it and
run with it i feel the same way about
the mvp but i get a vote on the heisman
by next
sunday
i have to i i this this weekend
like i have to
i don't know who i'm voting for well and
can i just say something
i i know the heisman's supposed to be i
don't really know what most outstanding
player is
but if they had the mvp in college
football
it's kenny pickett i mean
pitt
you know people talk about bryce young
he's a nice player cj stroud nice player
what do you think pitt's record would be
if those kids played for pitt what do
you think alabama and ohio state track
would be with kenny pickett played for
that i mean can he pick it
to have pit where they are you got to
play in big games you got to be you got
to be in the you know top 10 you got to
be relevant and as and as fun as he is
to watch and that game against wake
forest is going to be awesome
he's just not playing in meaningful
games you know you have your heisman
moment
and
you know he hasn't he hasn't had that
opportunity it's really important to
have that moment that stand-alone game
all right then let's go and i'm going to
try to change your mind let's go with
aidan hutchinson from michigan then all
right or the nose tackle for georgia
well jordan davis i that's who i would
probably vote for today
and i go back to and i love defensive
tackles for some reason i fall in love
with him way too much than i should like
i'll go back and steve entman who played
at washington i uh you know dominican
sioux where i just watched these guys in
college and i go god that guy's awesome
and i'll come in on monday and tell
these guys this nose tackle is awesome
you know
will i vote for a defensive player sure
absolutely and he might be the best
player
well why don't we why does anybody ever
mention stetson bennett
i mean if gino toretto won it or guys
like uh i don't know ken dorsey i'm sure
went to new york he's playing really
well
on the best team in the country
he's a good player
his numbers aren't huge we're not going
to do that anymore we're not going to do
that it's not going to happen because
people will go oh my god gino toretta
won a heisman
jason white
like that as a voter you know when
people say how could you vote for i said
well i wasn't voting back then but you
had to almost
defend why you would vote for the best
the quarterback on the best team
who wasn't the best player most valuable
player on his own team it defies logic
but those guys won heisman trophies
that's right that's the stetson bennett
argument i guess it's like anything else
in life you can always point to one
example from like 10 years ago well he
did it so he should do it
who's the best defensive tackle you ever
faced
richard seymour
richard seymour is the best defensive
lineman i ever faced
he should be in the hall of fame dan he
was extremely gifted
he had incredible technique
and he was legitimately mean like he
played hard so in all sincerity
d lyman wait what what's up
what's it mean that he plays mean
well so i went against a bunch of d
tackles that were probably more talented
than richard
but they just didn't play hard all the
time you know if you're a really gifted
guy
you don't have to you can kind of pick
your spots seymour was trying to kick
your you-know-what he was a mean
aggressive player and i know that
everybody thinks well every football
player is like that right not really
there's some 325 pound freak show d
tackles that just kind of pick their
spots they're not really trying you know
they want to make a couple plays but
they're not trying to beat richard
seymour was trying to beat you down he's
an interesting example i talked to him
about this when he played for the
patriots when he resigned there
his second contract
he knew
that it might hurt him for awards like
the hall of fame because in new
england's defense you must play the run
for the first two seconds along the line
of scrimmage so he knew he would never
have the warren sapp
tackle for loss
sack numbers
but if new england was going to
compensate him for that
he was okay with it but i'm here to tell
you right now if he played if he and sap
switched
seymour
puts up sap numbers or better sapp could
not have done what seymour did in new
england as a 3-4-2 gapping defensive end
talking to ross tucker uh are the rams
okay
i'm not so sure
you know it's like when they played the
titans
and the titans beat them up
up front
it doesn't feel like they've really
recovered
you know i mean even the last game
andrew whitworth who i love rashaan gary
and kenny clark yeah all of a sudden the
rams offensive line went from a strength
to a liability i mean they're getting
beat up
by some of these d lines up front and
then on their d-line
donald von miller
not as dominant as they had been i think
stafford misses robert woods and
i'm not sure if you heard this dan
matthew stafford this is gonna be hard
to believe breaking news play the
breaking news okay
matthew stafford is a professional
football player
playing through injuries
[Laughter]
man
is is he the only guy who's playing
through an injury ross
every week we hear a new report
about a quarterback that's playing
i mean that is can you imagine how hard
it must be to drop back four yards and
throw a football while something on your
body hurts
it's a good thing none of the offensive
and defensive linemen that are smashing
into each other every play have anything
bothering them physically
i mean give me a break here's the rule
everybody watching everybody listening
the rule is if you go inside those white
lines number one
everybody's hurting number two nobody
cares
if i said
you can have there's going to be an 18
game schedule
and they'll give you an extra bye week
would the players sign up for one more
game more money
and an extra bye week
so the top five percent of the players
the stars
would not
because that one game
incrementally financially is not worth
it to them
and they don't want the wear and tear
they're already making millions of
dollars a year
from
the 16th or maybe even the 15th guy on
the roster
all the way down to 80
they are volunteering and saying heck
yes here's what i always say dan okay
you know most these guys you know if
you're getting 1.7 million or you're
getting the minimum take a hundred
thousand dollars a week okay if you went
into the locker room on christmas eve
and he said hey guys
dan patrick just called he wants to know
if we'll play
buffalo
on january 16th you guys all get another
paycheck you all get another hundred
grand
every guy except for maybe the four or
five stars would be like heck yes we're
already here we already went through
training camp we already went through
the whole season we're already going to
be here until january 9th all i have to
do is go to two more practices that week
play one more game
for another 100 000
when by the way i might get cut next
year i might get hurt i might never make
this money again the rest of my life
where do i sign
at least 40 of the guys would sign
immediately in the locker room it's
always great to talk to you love when
you're fired up you've got i'm always
fired up you got army navy
next saturday my favorite day of the
year every year
if you've never been i know you have but
if other people haven't been if you're
not feeling great about the country find
a way to go to the army navy game you'll
watch everything
you'll take a deep breath and you'll say
okay we're going to be okay we're going
to be all right
he's ross tucker otherwise known as
meathead james van der beek
spicy mustard for life thank you buddy
see you there ross tucker football
podcast worked for cbs in westwood one